ZocDoc is a free app that shows you
doctors who are patient reviewed take
your insurance and are available when
you need them I mean speaking of when
you need them go to zocdoc.com trash and
download the ZocDoc app for free then
start your search for a top-rated doctor
today many are available within 24 hours
that's z o c doc.com trash zocdoc.com
trash today let's make a special shout
out to our favorite adult friendly
platform fansley the best platform to
connect one-on-one with your favorite
creators in a new and more intimate way
than ever before
chat unlock exclusive content watch live
streams and connect your Twitch or
Twitter to see if creators you already
engage with are on fansley today what
are you waiting for check out
fansley.com that's fansley
f-a-n-s-l-y.com for exclusive content
from your favorite creators and now a
word from our sponsor betterhelp easy
and affordable online therapy when you
want to be a better Problem Solver
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better health better
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday
you guys welcome to this trash Tuesday
you can see me this weekend September
23rd through 24th at the Arizona Tempe
Improv you can see me September 30th
this one I'm so excited for at the
coluso casino guys it's one night only
it's going to be so fun then in October
you can see me in Kansas City more dates
to come go to annieleterman.com shows
Hello friends and family and sluggies I
am going to be on the road doing
stand-up in Phoenix and in San Francisco
Seattle and Portland you can get tickets
at estheronice.com and check out my new
solo podcast Esther povitzky my pleasure
and that is available everywhere you
listen to your podcasts
foreign
I diagnosed her I definitely have a
sinus infection when I looked it up
that's what it is so and then he did
give me amoxicillin which is what they
say to do and I have a few more days
left so I'm hoping that that's just gone
look a former nurse can only take you so
far you need a Jew I know so with your
dream Powers combined my advice was get
a chest x-ray because I was more worried
about ambulatory pneumonia when it turns
out I it was up top I could hear I could
just because it is just it's the nasal
drip giving me the cough yeah it's going
back you know when you get a piece of
rice stuck in your nose you know as a as
a frequent rice eater I have never had a
rice stuck in my nose this could be my
specific deviated septum but you've
never how do you eat rice oh okay
comment below if you've ever had the
thing where when you accidentally inhale
a piece of rice and it goes in and out
and you're like you have to hock it then
suck it back in hock it and then
eventually get it out comment below and
if if I get no comments agree with me
I'll assume the person choked to death
comment below if you're Asian and this
has actually happened to you because we
know how to eat rice properly I'm so
sorry I'm sorry I'm not even hot I'm so
sick of having to apologize wait you've
been accepted into the Asian community
Through Todd thank you so much wait no
no I am a very messy sloppy eater I have
been known to eat macaroni and cheese
and have it on my forehead I don't want
to be rude but those nostrils are not
sucking anything in enough
you get rice in your that's like creepy
I have a I have a theory that it's
probably from your throat and it kind of
you know back travels up right now yes
and out that way and you don't actually
inhale the rice no no it's not like I'm
snorting right I mean maybe who knows
you guys I'm a wild child
um Annie I love your nails they're
sparking Joy thank you so much I got oh
this was again Ryan at Pinky's Nails you
got to go to this guy he I just want I
want aliens and he just went crazy he
went nuts for me
I feel like we missed out an opportunity
at Burning Man no no guys are so [ __ ]
pissed I didn't go to burning man but I
was like the last minute I was like
maybe I'll go to burning man that's not
a thing you could do last minute people
prepare for like right and it's like a
lottery system and it's like you have no
we're not a part of the lotteries no
we're not and no we're public figures I
actually would like to see you go to
Burning Man last minute I with no
preparation I'd like to drag your ass
like I want to [ __ ] Knock You Out
wake me up okay man sound just knock you
out and he's like you're trapped in
[ __ ] Burning Man wait oh my God you
guys Esther can't ride a bike how is she
gonna get across the Playa they have to
ride bikes she would be Medevac she
would get a [ __ ] they'd met a back
her to the other side
[Laughter]
oh no I wanted to go I did listen this
could be this could be real okay I said
to Whitney I was like because my friend
Abby luck who's this amazing artist
she's incredible look up her Instagram
and look at our YouTube together that we
did sausage party presents
but she um I don't know why I'm so
promotional today and check me out on
Twitter um so then so she always goes to
Burning Man and she was like look if you
want to come but it was during Whitney's
birthday week and for some reason I
thought we were gonna all do something
for Whitney's birth I forgot that Wendy
she canceled it yeah how did you find
out because today I said oh can we bring
people and she just said it's canceled
I'm like it's in three days no one told
me oh no she texted me personally and
said hey
um it's canceled did you know it's
actually not canceled guys it's just me
too
her 9 11 birthday party
this [ __ ] had her birth was gonna have
her birthday party at 9 11. my favorite
holiday I know oh Esther Esther did she
liked that holiday because it just had
to do with tall things she didn't have
anything to do with it wait can we get
back to how Esther's gonna travel across
the Playa at Burning Man outside of a
Medevac
I'm right here dare I say wheelchair
what was your fake an injury and he just
put a little one of those engines behind
it oh my god do you want one of the
you're not supposed to call them
um electric chairs of the power ones
okay we'll get you one of those chairs
but they don't go fast enough we gotta
really um oh my God that's so funny we
add like a motor on it wait and there
was a sandstorm imagine Esther
in the middle of a sandstorm and we're
not gonna have a seatbelt so we'll have
to duct tape or two oh my God I need to
know do you actually want to go to I 100
want to go why tell me what you want to
happen there I want to either do drugs
or watch people do drugs I am actually
currently doing no drugs right now I
guess NyQuil counts for Esther oh yeah
wait do you know Jay Moore had to go to
can you look this up did Jay Moore have
to go to rehab for NyQuil that's a lie I
don't know I don't know him so this is
pure [ __ ] talk this is not like a
personal attack this is a
a non-personal attack yeah wait see I
tripped on it like Ayahuasca level like
had to like deal with the death of my
family myself and my dog I thought I
thought I had been visited by my Shaman
I have been promised by my new Shaman
that if I don't do Ayahuasca he will
bring me on an Ayahuasca journey in my
dreams and I was like he arrived he's
here should we get high on day cool or
NyQuil during our next live stream show
yeah Whitney did mushrooms How does
Whitney do the exact same thing wait can
we try something a little more fun we
can do mushrooms too right of course
like you know we did it before she did
it so I don't want to say I'm not saying
she's stole but I'm just saying I think
weed is the for me like I'm experienced
at it no we don't want you to be
experienced at it right Esther you've
got to take mushrooms with me for the
first time that is not the point okay
are we gonna you can't just [ __ ] up
that's right I can't believe you didn't
make a move on Stella I'm like actually
embarrassed no I I respect I I like love
her and respect I need to get to know
her CLI Liars got the name tattoo I'm
ready to just come forward and say let's
rock I thought you're gonna say you go
to Stella tattoo too I'm like if one
more tattoo gets on that [ __ ] body
and it's not my name I had a dream of
crazy fomo dream last night I've really
been trying to look at my dreams like
what my subconscious needs to tell me
but I was like that's so funny and that
was so genuine and real because some I
love I love to read into the
subconscious of my dreams we were all on
like it was all these comedians you guys
were there too and we were on
um it was like us Theo was there Gary
veteran randomly I don't know if you
know him it was just a bunch of us on
this like cruise ship but it was also a
spaceship and there were either you said
us maybe I you know when it Blends
together I think you I honestly do think
you were there I think everyone was our
Pete was there sweating his pits out and
there were all these really incredible
activities you could do like weird
skydiving things like this crazy
um this was a cruise ship in the sky
okay this is the dream of a 12 year old
I just want to be clear a cruise ship in
the sky when you end up hearing what
happens it's gonna be very 12. this is
way better than Bert than burning yes it
was very it was like you want desert how
about cruise ship in the sky so then
okay so then yes it was like that
it's like the Enterprise okay so then
but you could go on like a really cool
like water slide that's like down into
the clouds right I'm on board what we're
happening where I would have to get out
of line and I couldn't get do the
activities everyone else could do them
and then I was about to do it and
they're like you can't do it we're
having a surprise party for kalila and I
was like I can't miss kalila's [ __ ]
surprise party so I was like all right
and I had to go down and I was like what
is this do you know who was throwing it
by chance
um
I mean probably Theo
but Theo had posted this like him going
down the water slide I was like are you
[ __ ] kidding me oh wait and the
reason I was missing everything was
because I had found out there was some
girl who I wasn't friends with but for
some reason I was like invested in her
life who had come with her baby and she
was living in this apartment upstairs
this is so boring to talk about dreams
I'm so sorry but and then someone had
cheated her boyfriend was cheating on
her and she found out about it and I was
somehow in the middle of it and I was
like trying to help her through that and
I [ __ ] missed all the fun okay I
think I can interpret your dream yeah I
think it's because you've been sick for
three weeks you haven't been able to
like Fully live your fullest best life
so you're just like in your head your
worst fear is like people are on a
cruise ship in the sky without me yeah I
need to get rid of this sinus infection
but it's always sad being there and not
being able to do it too I was like yes
well it's the same thing as in real life
because just because you're sick at home
doesn't mean you don't know what's going
on because you're looking at social
media and stuff like I think that I
honestly wasn't looking that much thank
God I think I would if I looked at it
but it was fomo and it felt like I was
jealous of people for doing things and
then I so then I was like I went on
inside timer do you guys have that app
do you ever look at that no it's just an
app of like it has different meditations
and different like spiritual talks and
stuff and sometimes when I'm just like I
want to hear like
some Shaman say something I just will go
on it but I went on it and I typed in
jealousy like because I want to know
what the root of it was and I randomly
got on this two minute uh Thing by who's
the guy sad Guru is he good or bad I'm
not sure I'm always afraid they [ __ ]
everyone like uh all the gurus are like
bang like big girls yeah they haven't
changed everything to 26 and two he's
gonna take his name off of everything
she was like not as sexy at all I know I
used to love Bikram Yoga you can still
go it's still almost 26 and 2 is Vikram
that's okay I don't feel like it anymore
the 90 minute class is the one you
missed you [ __ ] liar yeah hour and a
half
the longest yoga class
um but so he there was this story and I
can't remember the whole thing even
though it was only two minutes but it
was like this woman stood up and she was
like this was not even on the train of
thought I was trying to go on but I
thought it was interesting she goes
um I is jealousy really bad because
jealousy has actually like helped me
like when I'm jealous of people I ended
up like I got into my dream school
because I was jealous my friend got in
and it made me work harder and he told
this story this old story about how they
used to bring
donkeys into this town and they would
put
um uh firecrackers like in a tin and
they'd let them off and the donkeys
would like run really fast and he's like
do you want to have like firecrackers on
your tail like do you want to be the
donkey like running or do you want to be
like enjoying succeeding and then also
if you get used to that being your
motivation is that your your tail is on
fire like your tail is gonna be [ __ ]
up like I mean obviously I'm fair for
anything this but I thought that was
interesting I think I was super super
insane crazy jealous person in my early
20s like I could not turn my jealousy
into like positive aspiration like I was
like locked in and Paralyzed by my
jealousy especially over boys and girls
that were that I was threatened by and I
think a lot of it has to do with like my
mom always pitting me against someone my
whole life always like looking outward
and saying like things about people look
at this person doing this look at this
person doing this and me never feeling
like I I was that person for her but I I
think the how I got over it was doing
nothing at all and just growing up yeah
like when I got to my 30s and I'm like
there's [ __ ] nothing I can do it just
like I just kind of went away it's also
so stressful it's like I was destructive
you guys like on MySpace like I would
like she's like it's my space not your
space [ __ ]
Tom Tom you piece of [ __ ] you're on
everyone's first number one friend I was
just so insecure about every everything
that happened in my life and it would
drive me up a [ __ ] wall like I would
I wouldn't be able to like sleep at
night I don't think I know anyone who
got through their 20s without dealing
with like jealousy or insecurity like I
think that's so normal like toxic I look
at Jules and she's like I don't give a
[ __ ] okay well that's bad I'm like wow
are you sociopath are people healthier
now because there's like so therapy
online is it better help better help
eradicate yesterday after you left
Esther said something that blew my
[ __ ] I couldn't have more fomo when I
came back then you guys were talking I
was like they're [ __ ] talking still
what are they talking about on our way
out on our way to the cart she said that
she's like yeah I as soon as I wake up
in the morning I brush my teeth and I
thought I think that's the craziest
thing I've ever heard to hear from her
specifically
okay and I've never brush them again
before coffee and before breakfast
are you crazy yes of course wait you're
telling me you want minty coffee or
minty orange juice because the the it
there's always the flavor of the food
Annie help me out I support you yes do
you want to eat your breakfast I don't
want scum bacteria in your mouth no just
gargle with water no so that it don't
say that like that's a normal thing I'll
go with water no my mom says that
darling you just have to gargoyle with
water
explains a lot
um wait so what you know you're supposed
to brush your teeth like after every
meal too right I do that but it is I do
like the idea of just getting you don't
do that do you brush your teeth in your
shower oh yeah
shower or toothbrusher yeah even with my
electric in there yeah me too I have a
tongue scraper yeah so I my priority is
after a meal obviously but before a meal
no it's going to
um destroy the palate the like the the
neutral the neutrality of your palette I
don't eat right away though oh because I
eat right I go and I've been here this
is one of the good things about my I'm
kind of on board with your anti-sadness
walk even though I don't like
anti-sadness because you're using
sadness in the thing and in hypnosis
you're not supposed to have the word in
it but I appreciate you we're preventing
sadness before it sets yes before it
goes in uh we're like preventative Botox
for your feelings but so I've been
walking I was thinking about like the
sickness sucks but I can't exercise so
I've been just going on long walks and
it's been [ __ ] amazing okay well I'm
personally attacked oh that's what I'm
saying walking are you saying walking is
an exercise
here's what I like about Esther she can
do the least this is what I like about
us if she can do the least and she can
spin it in her head like she's doing the
most
and that's really all that matters as a
as a a full believer of hypnotism that's
all that matters us I have a different
take I think when I think about walking
I think it's the most
it's the most difficult thing for me to
agree to do working out doing hit
training an hour of that I could do it I
should say Okay commit but walking to me
I will not [ __ ] walk out because your
thoughts you have to be in your thoughts
[ __ ] maybe I have to sit there and I
have to look down at the concrete I like
hiking if it's like you know it's
aggressive yeah but what I realized is
like I am accepting it as exercise
because I have no other option because I
can't I really like it's in my because
you're at your Rock Bottom I'm on my
rock bottom which also Esther walks at
the bottom of the rock she never goes up
it but um
but it is like it's been really nice my
friend I was talking to her and she
mentioned something to her she goes I go
on Bliss walks oh that's great so she
goes and like mushrooms are involved
I've always been involved since the tale
since the dawn of time
but but I was thinking I was like I need
to just like turn my head off and go out
and then it's like I don't have to think
about things if I want to I can think
about my jokes and stuff it's kind of
like a really way to easefully go
through things and I understand why you
can't talk on the walk yes walks are the
[ __ ] best like
I look forward to my walk so much I
think they literally give me like how
long do you walk for an hour
um I like yeah 45 minutes to an hour is
like a good yeah and I'm sweating a
little bit I am actually sweating yeah
talking is effective and I also I walk
fast I have you do walk right I thought
that was just when I was with you you're
gonna get away
for someone so small you have really big
strides yeah she's also falling forward
as well
I do get that comp you've gotten more
coordinated thank you maybe as you've
lost weight and your tits have shrunk a
little bit
have they no they haven't I'm just
kidding oh my God do not take my insults
seriously I haven't been able to work
out in three years you gotta do your
walks you gotta start doing them I'm
trying I rip my shoulder so I'm going
I'm a physical therapy today right after
this but I feel that same way where it's
like it's like a hell you're in yeah I
was in a really good workout routine
again too like I finally was like this
is like in my identity I feel like
someone that just has to exercise every
day it's just a part of my life it
doesn't feel hard
and I just Wham yeah the first week back
especially is a big mental barrier like
how do how did I do this for so long
yeah it is crazy that that never goes
away you never working out whenever it
gets easy like you think you do it so
that it'll get easy
well your ego like doesn't want you to
do anything that's good for you it just
wants you to be safe and fat and comfy
where you can't be killed that's also
kind of fun though
that sounds really good I'm sick of
being sick and fat and comfy I'm tired
of it
I'm tired of just laying
well it's like you want to identify
quality right because if you're a fan of
it Sushi is incredible but gas station
Sushi is not incredible I've had a few
but you would have to know that you
would have to know is this application
you should go to which you would know
yes I would know honestly it would be me
because finding the right Sushi makes
all the difference and that same thing
goes for finding the right doctor and
that's why I am addicted to ZocDoc it's
really the best especially my doctor's
been out of town and I needed a doctor
it's like so hard to find what has your
insurance and all that stuff so when you
can just go on ZocDoc you can find
someone that takes your insurance has
good reviews it's just so much easier
dude I'm so glad you said that because
like knowing if they're in your network
are they close by you like these things
are important and they're all available
to find out on ZocDoc and look
battleship is a fun board game a lot of
us played as kids but as an adult
calendar battleship is a frustrating
game that you play with your doctor I'm
not down for that okay zoc Doc is a free
app that shows you doctors who are
patient reviewed take your insurance and
are available when you actually need
them and on ZocDoc doc you can find
every specialist Under the Sun whether
you're trying to straighten your teeth
fix an achy back get them all checked
out anything else Sock Doc has you
covered all things I've had to do in the
past three months all things in the last
three minutes you can find and review
local doctors read verified patient
reviews from real people who made real
appointments and now when you walk into
your doctor's office you're set to see
someone that's in your network who
actually gets you go to zocdot.com find
the Doctor Who is right for you and book
an appointment in person or remotely
that works for your schedule every month
millions of people use ZocDoc and I am
one of them it's my go-to whenever I
need to find and book quality doctors go
to zocdoc.com trash and download the
ZocDoc app for free then then start your
search for a top-rated doctor today and
many are available within 24 hours
that's Z O C
doc.com slash trash I will be zoc
docking today
sockdoc.com trash truly there's no
reason not to
today's podcast is brought to you by
fanslee an Innovative adult friendly
platform allowing you to connect
intimately with content creators think
Tick Tock but for spicy content and
exclusive access to your faves follow
subscribe message creators to chat
one-on-one unlock pay-per-views you
definitely won't see anywhere else and
discover new favorites on fansies for
you page where new creators are
suggested based on the ones that you're
already in love with you can also sign
up through Twitter or twitch to see if
creators you already follow are also on
fansly I'm just so grateful there's a
platform that is very supportive of
adult friendly content because we're
giving and supporting the actual
creators as opposed to like some shady
old system like how it used to be and
fans and fansley even protects your
content with free copyright takedowns
and chargeback protection and welcomes
creators of all fan base sizes whether
you're already established or just
beginning and the average creator with a
thousand followers on social media earns
about 500 a month on Ansley what are you
waiting for sign up today at fansley.com
that's fans oh no she's proud of me
um that's fansley
f-a-n-s-l-y.com for exclusive content
from your favorite creators
[Music]
okay so what's the what's the news
um in terms of new merch so we have
decided that because we're the three
most beautiful women in the world that's
true clearly we are going we better
we're going to shoot a calendar for 2023
and we need to decide who is going to
get what months
and yeah wait are we doing singles I
think we'll do a mix of singles and and
oh my God that's so sad there's like one
people just don't like
um
favorite and your least favorite let's
be real okay wait
um so February is only 28 days and is is
this year leap year or not
no right
um so one of us will get the least
exposure if someone gets February I mean
I think the shortest
well I think maybe February because
Valentine's Day should be for like the
love connection oh that's an easy
ew I'm already excluded I see what this
is this is Esther making her move she's
like we should be 69ing me and kalila
for Valentine's Day that's fine I can be
in the back like this with my my glasses
on my pedophile glasses do you know you
should do that they know that Annie and
I have scissored right you weren't
around when you're in Palm Springs oh
for a long time and my mom was taking
the pictures I think yeah my feet were
in them though so they didn't get posted
maybe they didn't get posted they didn't
get posted I think I was feeling chub
okay
does anyone have a strong feeling about
a month that they really want I mean I
have to get my birthday yeah we should
do our birthday my birthday yeah okay
which is I get November I Miss November
oh I Miss March
July oh okay good we're not fighting
over the flies in July's okay and I I
think that I don't want the all of the
winter months that seems a little
depressing for me maybe we could do like
make it a different kind of calendar and
it can have like a Hanukkah theme for
now
to for the underrepresented out there
I guess we're widely represented in
media I know there's so many Jewish
holidays I always know when my agent
doesn't pick up I'm like it's a [ __ ]
another Jewish okay so when is Passover
I uh April okay so you get April then
too you get the big Jewish holiday I
know she has no clue she guessed so hard
it is April okay April
I'll take April but Easter would be cute
if you were like on the can oh wait I
have so many ages I actually don't want
to burn the ideas okay I think that
I'll be us I'm gonna be a sexy Passover
bunny yeah Passover bunny yeah like
instead of Easter I want to pass over
that idea
but maybe people can't give us ideas
well for July you're a cancer just be a
crab you had crabs right I should always
be like yeah I know exactly what to do
for that actually
July is crab month
it's crab Awareness Month
by the way it's also a pube Awareness
Month turns out you gotta have pubes for
it I um
it's crabs the symbol is 69 and it's
cancer it's a dark one yeah it's a dark
one I have that's so weird do you think
we include Carlos to the calendar at all
it really depends on Carlos do you want
to do a Yoko Ono John Lennon no let's
not do that you've already done one with
Bobby not the yukono one Bobby and I
have done crazy honestly I might have
just looked at the Yoko Ono one and
thought it was you guys oh no we did for
Halloween we Bobby was Yoko I was John
Lennon no but the pose you know when
they're um doing like this it's like a
Infamous like Rolling Stone cover or
something like that what's gay pride
month July then maybe we should do like
uh June we should do like that one
almost like sextup ones like me and
Carlos like this oh wow
oh my gosh wait Carlos could do that so
well because he's so skinny oh yeah I'll
definitely be John Lennon in that oh
guys I'm so uncomfortable
I feel re-molested right now or actually
can this be your dad
wait yeah I mean yeah you think your dad
would fly over here almost has that butt
doesn't it kind of look like a Carlos
that's the fetal I have a better butt
than that is this is English you've
never seen this no is this like
symbolizing that like she's his mommy or
something probably wait why do you look
like Sean Lennon right now to me what
the [ __ ] [ __ ] I love Sean London no no
don't do it pull it up wait I like Sean
Lennon I like John Lennon oh my God his
song with Lana Del Rey's oh good
that's why you were looking at it why
look at him he's beautiful oh no my
doppelganger
it's so funny
why does he look like he murdered his
parents on that one down there
that one doesn't look like he's on trial
for killing his parents
that's so specific oh do you know what
he looks like to me he looks like a a
what would be the baby of like Todd and
Dave
he really does honestly it really does
throw a Bobby in there too
guys I relapsed on murder oh no that's
why I can tell when things look like
they're trial pictures because I've been
really going into which ones which ones
I'm sober from watching crime shows I
think I'm not smoking I'm not gonna
smoke weed until I make one million
dollars I mean 100 million dollars those
are so different 100 million dollars
a million is not hard
wait are you you're really like not
doing weed for that it's it's really
[ __ ] my life up it's really does not
help me it just really really really
deters me from all of my dreams I don't
think it does that for everyone I really
don't but it does for me I overeat I
stay up late I don't wash my make it's
like basic things and then huge things
will you I don't show up to things other
things instead of weed maybe I mean
obviously for special occasions I do
things yeah yeah and things like that
but I'm I haven't like said I'm
definitely not gonna do mushrooms or
anything like that it's just it's not
like
I'm just not
I'm not partaking yeah
but murder I got I think as I was like
getting so depressed from being sick
because I really do believe it's like do
whatever you guys want like live your
lives but it is like not filling you
with a good loving Viber I'm trying to
live on the vibrational level of love
and peace and if you're watching murders
it's just not there which ones are you
watching though I watch why I watch the
Army Hammer thing which is just crime
that's not a murder right and then
um well actually there was a murder in
there I think his dad or his grandfather
got accused of murder but um
I want I just started watching some
basic
date lines it just started creeping in
and I watched I watched one that I'd
already seen too and I was like this is
really sick to re-watch one I was like I
know who did it
um
and I just yeah I just but I was just
being aware of it I was going okay I'm
going down this road I'm just aware of
it and uh I've been good at night but
you know what I realized it is if you
watch murder there's a million shows on
TV to watch where you have so much you
have everything to watch if you don't
watch murder you run out of shows you
know what show I think you're gonna love
if you haven't already started is Yellow
Jackets Yellow Jackets I did like the
first season but I didn't see the
music's really good they play Garbage
they play all the 90s songs um Julia
Juliette Lewis isn't it who I really
want on this show
um Christina Ricci
um it is such so far I'm only on like
the third episode it is so freaking good
and well done yeah what I highly highly
recommend okay highly recommend yeah is
the second season good though I haven't
started the second season I literally
just started the the first season yeah I
have a question I really want to like
think this through and figure this out
why do women like watching murder shows
do we know like what is it in us that
makes us want to watch them because men
don't really like them the way way women
like that but men do like them men do I
think we said sounds like they're like
co-opted it as like oh it's what we do
as like Housewives we watch crime and we
make it our identity but it's like I
think everyone watches them is there any
chance that we're watching it to like
subconsciously learn how not to get
murdered I don't know because every time
you see one of those murders there's
like she loved Dateline no but I always
say it well my favorite show was snapped
was women doing the murdering
so I I mean maybe you know it's it's
good to know how not to get murdered but
it's also good to know how to murder I
would say if you go on not how not not
yeah not how not to murder if you go on
any First Dates anytime don't tell them
that you like that show oh I watch The
Craigslist Killer I watch The Craigslist
Killer I actually have never seen
snapped is that the classic that's the
classic you you've seen it's women that
go nuts and just murder yeah
I like to identify with the victim
believe it or not we believe I'm not
really an aggressor I have no you know
what it is it's like I'm really not
gonna ever be able to kill someone I'm
five feet tall I'm 100. they will never
guess it's coming you could murder the
[ __ ] out of someone you cut their
Achilles heel like in a pet cemetery oh
you just slice it so I can just hide
under the bed and slice
that is yeah do you remember that movie
do you know the premise of pet cemetery
is it that pets from the dead pets come
alive and kill her well there's one
there's one ceremony that our ceremony
there's one Cemetery where when your pet
dies you can bury it and they come back
to life but they're evil but they do
come back so we know worth it yeah and
you get killed by a donut I would that's
me and Dave's dream evil Donuts we
literally like donut please eat Us Alive
in our sleep tonight we want you to take
us out like that would be the best way
to go who would get donut Jenna
um who watches donut
me Carlos Carlos Jenna but I think my I
think well before covet hit when I
thought me and Dave were for sure gonna
die I wrote a long email to Carlson
Jenna with instructions on how to take
care of donut and you didn't think they
were gonna die just you guys yeah I just
assumed that like because they're both
Mexican that their immune systems are
stronger than ours as Jews and so it's
like they'll one of them will take it
such different looking types of Mexicans
you too Jenna yeah yeah I mean I like
secret Mexicans well Jenna's Jewish too
yeah did you take that into
consideration I feel that when you're
mixed you're stronger isn't that like a
thing I don't know that's what my egg
doctor said I have a lot of autoimmune
stuff my eye doctor was like so excited
that Todd was Asian really yeah he was
like this is going to be great you guys
are going to mix together perfectly are
you serious stronger embryos yeah is
that a fact that's what he said I don't
know I believe it Dr Wong said this oh
[ __ ] well I gotta have him on here by
the way it makes sense because like you
guys are less likely to be carrying
exactly you wouldn't have taste sacks or
I don't know what the other ones are
called there's a bunch of them taste sex
is the only one I know
but yeah there's there we're not inbred
but it feels like we are what does that
exactly mean like you literally make
babies with your brother yes can you not
act like you don't know what incestors I
just don't I'm gonna rape you like a
sibling not everyone turns out like the
Lannisters or the American they're just
like a little blonde yeah
more platinum blonde now your eyes are a
little cross is there something you want
to tell us I mean you said it's you know
mixed breeds are stronger it turns out
they come out cross-eyed you're not
cross-eyed
so 0.2 percent of all marriages in the
US are between second cousins or closer
what I think second cousins this seems
like nothing nothing yeah because I feel
like in Asia they do that a lot to keep
the wealth in the family I have first
cousins who are very hot
my legal in Most states really that's
illegal first because I had kind of a
crush on my cousin and then he turned
out to be gay I was like Ugh
finally reason to not kiss
that's why he's not into me
um but yeah like uh brother sister
especially if there's like some genetic
thing you're for sure gonna have but
isn't there like a thing there has to be
a thing where like pheromonally you
don't match like I'm not attracted my
brother is my twin I should think he's
gorgeous but I don't like I'm not
attracted to my siblings at all like I
never was like damn when they were like
putting on their shorts or anything like
I never yeah because yours was your
stepbrother too so it's not like it was
yeah it's my Paul Rudd yeah so that's
fine but it's like isn't there something
there's got to be something that keeps
you from like wanting to [ __ ] I know but
if you're let's suppose like in a deep
in the forest somewhere and that's
really awesome and you've never seen
anything else because I was so boy crazy
I joined the boys baseball team to be
around boys like I was around I loved
boys I was like you know just wanted to
be near them and but I
did not want to [ __ ] my brothers yeah
and I I mean it from the bottom of my
house so sorry Max and Tim I love you
guys I can understand your good looking
guys but I don't feel it in my loins
that's I mean that is how I feel about
my guy friends too it's like when I
think about them I'm like when people
say that I'm like I love them so much I
love them but no yeah like it's just
yeah but that's different but it feels
the same if you've ever had a brother
though no well I have a brother
Duncan but he was that's incestor it
wasn't Duncan didn't he start as yours
no uh that was perfect oh okay Duncan
died yeah Duncan passed away last last
fall we should my mom's gonna start
crying so let's oh Mom he had a good
life I mean you know he had an okay life
we got to get another we gotta get
another one did she get another one they
have pepper and so they don't want they
say they don't want anyone Peppers
pepper is really putting them through
the ringer these days yeah [ __ ] in their
bedroom a couple nights ago I was
thinking today I was thinking about what
we were talking about with Stella about
like motherhood and and not
um not having kids is like a form of
like motherly love and and paternal or
maternal instincts and so I was when I
was walking Randy and I was like I just
love him like I'm always like come on
guy let's go little one like I love you
like whenever he's like being annoying
I'm just like scooch ahead come on like
I'm so kind to him my old dogs I would
be like if you don't take a [ __ ] I will
die like I would be stoned I wouldn't
like hurt them or anything but I would
be so mad I would like have anger
towards the dog do you know what I mean
like the dog that's my fault if they
don't know how to take a [ __ ] but also
it's like I motherhood can really test
like you can go into motherhood being
like I'll never you know rage out at my
kid but that [ __ ] will test it when
you're sleep deprived I know when you
don't it's hard when you have like all
these tools but if you're sleep deprived
it's like you can't access them because
you're just [ __ ] yeah yeah it's I can
imagine how a lot of women can probably
feel like what the [ __ ] like why do I
[ __ ] hate this kid right now
you know like to hate something and love
it at the same time but I I guess I was
just like it was I felt like it was a
testament to my growth where I was like
I just have never mad at my it's like
seems insane I used to be mad at my dog
I also don't like the way like we treat
motherhood as in like our society I saw
this this Tick Tock of this guy he was
filming a woman who was on the phone and
she set her child like on bare concrete
and obviously like that was hard to
watch and made me uncomfortable but it's
like the guy is sitting is your heart
out
I'm not I don't know but it's just like
she was kind of leaving it unattended on
the concrete and he's sitting there
filming bitching about it but I'm like
well maybe if Society was better instead
of filming it to like shame her the mom
or you go help how about this just in
general like support mothers also like
don't come near me and my babies well
don't [ __ ] shame her with your phone
I don't want your [ __ ] help you
psycho also more than likely she's way
more able and capable than you will ever
be sir like shut the [ __ ] up like so in
America here's what I like the
difference between living in Asia
growing up there watching how motherhood
Works they're seeing my friends have
children and families there versus here
it's like we're supposed to be a first
world nation we number one do not
support mothers and shame them all day
shame them all [ __ ] day but don't
want to [ __ ] help them or put in or
or Implement things into law that
actually like create like happy Mothers
back home it's like the whole Community
is involved you could pass your baby
around there's always someone to help no
one is shaming anyone for a crying baby
no one is shaming anyone for anything
it's like you want to you know if the
only means of transportation is on a
[ __ ] Vespa and you're holding your
baby because you need to go to the
[ __ ] doctors that's just how it's
gonna be and it's like no one's [ __ ]
you know you know putting it on Tick
Tock saying look at this you know like
neglectful mother it's like dude
everyone's doing their [ __ ] best shut
the [ __ ] up I know it really rubbed me
the wrong way because it's like oh yeah
you want a rally behind this like oh my
God she put a baby on the concrete but
like she's struggling she's doing her
best like can I see how the baby's
sitting on the concrete I don't
understand why that doesn't sound that
bad
was it head first thrown on the concrete
no I honestly don't didn't say who cares
yeah no I'm glad you didn't save it
that's a good one to save Tick Tock to
me send you some weird ones or you know
how like everyone's shamed like Britney
for I think like being in a car and like
holding her baby this way it's like
those are very like american-centric
ideas of raising children you go to the
Philippines so you can [ __ ] stack
them up on top of your head and no one
was bad a [ __ ] eyelash you know what
I mean it's like she's she's a [ __ ]
country girl like it we don't have the
same laws to you know around like car
seats and whatnot because it's not no
one can afford a car seat so it's like
yeah so it's a very like
american-centric way and I understand
why those laws are there it's like to
prevent the baby from being ejected out
or whatever but also it's like if it's
like a one-off like give her a [ __ ]
break like nothing happened like just
give mothers a break
right I think Britney's just like
driving around other big uh Starbucks
I'm so happy for Brittany right now by
the way like talking [ __ ] to Kevin
Federline and talking back to her son is
so iconic naughty kids you're like your
dad has not had a job for 20 years 15
years and he makes he gets 40 000 a
month from her
yeah
and he has the nerve to try to like
cancel her that is absurd Kevin you are
nothing okay you're a [ __ ] nothing I
hate him you are my type though
um you're not not my type uh so keep it
up
um speaking of Kevin Federline as a type
did you guys see Jerry Seinfeld's uh
uh photo shoot was there anything like
I think it's cool
look at him I was honored to be part of
Ronnie so funny brilliant idea to do a
kiss collection that will benefit CNY
and my alma mater Queen's College all
right I thought this was cool like I
love seeing a comedian in like
mainstream fashion and like a different
or what what do you guys don't like it
what's the vibe it's so funny look at
him
it's a little hard to go from very
Seinfeld to that
he's like that's hot come on I mean he
looks like Sebastian does he look like
he's possibly targeting a younger
audience he's hot
he's hot I don't think he looks handsome
it's a great jacket that's hot
um I don't like that one
I I
is he reading a fake book what's he
doing
he's like the world is in your hands how
do you guys feel about like a a comic
Jerry Seinfeld
eventually becoming so [ __ ] Rich that
they become like out of touch like is
that like I just can't wait to have
those struggles uh like if someone can
can someone still be funny when you're
completely like just living in a bubble
of like Fame and money I think you can
probably be funny to like your close
friends but yeah probably not in like a
mainstream way like how can you do
observational comedy when you have
nothing to observe but your compound do
you know anywhere that you live in I
think you can do a different type of
Comedy I think that would be a hard one
to do but also I think it's like
I think what happens with these guys
with with the older richer comedians is
they don't want to like look at other
Comics they don't want to see other they
don't they're not seeing what other
comedy is they're not seeing what's
going on on Facebook they're not seeing
about like memes and stuff so then their
comedy ends up being like things we've
all heard before a lot of them where I'm
like this is not a hot take like if you
went to one Open Mic you'd see like 50
versions of the thing you just said I
have to say though I saw Chris Rock at
the comedy seller earlier this year
before the slap pre-slap Chris Rock and
uh his set was really good and it was I
felt like he was commenting on all the
right things in all the right ways and
it was almost like why why I was kind of
like why isn't there more hype around
Chris Rock like he's killing it he's the
comic we need and then he called up Will
Smith and goes you got to do me a favor
but she was dating Nick thune and then
went over to she was Chris Rock they're
such a hot hot can you believe that but
I think that
rock a Chris Rock Chappelle they still
like immerse themselves in the scene
right like you're not gonna see Jerry
Seinfeld at doing spots at The Comedy
Store Chappelle does Chris Rock does
you're right that you're not out of yeah
yeah if if Chris Rock is showing up The
Comedy tell her he's not out of touch
he's yeah checking in with the right
people look at that and probably
watching everyone yeah that is hot
they're so cute no I got to go up after
him it was so fun
he did an hour and then I went up and
smashed
now a word from our sponsor betterhelp
listen I'm all over the place it's like
I will get so busy I will forget that
I'm even like I'm not focusing on my
health I'm not focusing on the work I
need to get done I'm just completely
lost and I feel like that's something
that's really
been beneficial being able to talk to
someone to just help get my focus issues
like
together and you you need your better
help right now I want them to help me
form this sentence honestly well it's a
real thing so for me I know I will have
a tendency to focus on the problem when
I actually need to be focusing on the
solution and it's easy to say that but
it's when you're having your problems
it's really hard to actually figure out
that you need to do that and having
someone to talk to and just a safe space
where you feel like you can be yourself
and not be judged which I don't have
that anywhere other than in my therapy
session yeah that has helped me so much
to be a more solution oriented person
yeah they used to call me Brian Boitano
because I could triple Axel all of my
problems I was a spinner
up all night just really spinning and
you're just focusing on all of the bad
things none of the ways to get out of it
and better help is one of the most
amazing places to go where someone will
just sit with you and they will help you
just
Focus your brain on how to get out of it
when you want to be a better Problem
Solver therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better
h-e-l-p.com trash Tuesday
I've like I've avoided Tick Tock I think
I'm my whole existence is trying to
avoid Tick-Tock I have like people kind
of posting things and I'm not like
really involved and it's obviously not
going to grow that way and stuff and I'm
like oh I think I do want to like delve
into it but it's so overwhelming can I
be given maybe some
chat Twitter Tick Tock challenges like a
certain amount I have to post or things
I need to cry from you guys and maybe I
just still stand by my seam like old
advice with Tick Tock is like it's just
like whoever you are is who you'll be on
Tick Tock and so
just be yourself and then how many do
you do
how many did you have to do whatever you
want to commit whatever you feel like it
you do it you know yeah oh God I wanted
to ask you guys if you you watched the
Manti Teo um documentary I did watch it
I did watch someone educate me so Manti
Teo is a was a star from Punahou High
School in Hawaii
um and he eventually played for Notre
Dame for the Saints um but in somewhere
in like the earlier that's is that what
are their what's the name of it just
know the fighting who did he then go to
is that what they are he ended up on
some chargers chargers yeah yeah but
basically he um in high school he was a
star
um very very religious
um Mormon boy good boy never
um never strayed always walked the very
straight line
um everyone in his community loved him
he was also loved that no beloved at
Notre Dame
um but he always talked about his a
girlfriend in interviews and
um before one of I think the last game
of the season he um he announced he he
dedicated the game to his grandma that
had just passed and his girlfriend that
passed the very same day his grandma and
his girlfriend died the very same day
and
um later we find out that there was no
girlfriend and that basically he had
been catfished but
the worst part is that he was accused of
being in on the hoax and people accusing
him of being gay and Katie Couric how
[ __ ] rude of that [ __ ] to be like
are you gay dude the entire football
Community owes this guy he was like
[ __ ] College
whoa yeah it's so [ __ ] sad Esther
wait so did his grandma really die yeah
his grandma really died but so this this
is just wishful thinking that he was gay
everybody wants a piece of that look how
cute he is his girlfriend who her name
was Lynette kakua
um turns out to be a young man from La
pretending to be this girl it was before
catfishing was even a term yeah like we
didn't know what catfish was but right
around that time I got [ __ ] catfished
this was a time where you just kind of
couldn't Trust on my space I did
and um he went by Amorcito 888 his name
was Lorenzo and I thought he was a guy
from Australia my friends were like I
was like hey do you know this guy and
they're like yeah we know him but I
didn't ask how they knew him they knew
him just based on the same thing on
MySpace so I totally understand how he
could have been catfished because I fell
for the same [ __ ] but he also made
up a bunch of different profiles too and
like yeah yeah man talked to yeah so
this was the
um but now she's trash yeah she's
transitioned
um and but I like her hand tattoos
henna is that what that is is she
someone oh yeah so that was the girl
whose images
um she used and yeah he had somehow like
befriended this girl well they went to
high school today oh okay and then God
heard Ascend so like the one that was
really convincing was because every time
uh Mante Teo was asking to hang out with
her there was always an excuse and he's
like are you real what am I gonna see
you and so he sent a she sent a picture
of herself with like whatever he had
said to put on this yeah this is the day
this is the time you know how they used
to do that like prove to me that you're
real yeah so then it's like okay this is
definitely a real person yeah but so
what was it the catfish yeah had asked
this girl since they had gone to school
together hey can you can I take a
picture of you holding the sign and she
agreed because she was told that it was
before dying sick like sick something
yeah yeah and so
um this poor freaking star of an athlete
um basically didn't get chosen in the
first round draft because people were
like we don't want to deal with that and
he also started to the sad part was when
he was like how can you lead if you
don't like trust yourself like he had
lost his confidence in himself yeah and
he couldn't lead
uh the team the way that he had been
doing before it was like really sad but
then he had like a moment in therapy I
think that most people have had I know
I've had this moment that um the uh the
Matt Damon and and Robin Williams moment
where it's like it's not your fault it's
not your fault
and so he had to like learn to forgive
himself forgive his younger self for
making that kind of mistake that cost
him a career basically I'm here's where
I'm stumped how do you become boyfriend
and girlfriend without having sex
because it's poor man they didn't yeah
that much apparently and it would like
heat up every couple months and I think
he was just a young guy who like got
really really [ __ ] tricked also
didn't need to see her to like [ __ ]
feelings right and he was also really
she was such because ranaya or the
catfish played football in high school
and also came from a football family so
the catfish knew so much about football
that he was able she was able to give
him really good tips and really good
like hey babe you got this do this next
time do this yeah and um I also think
that here is a guy from Laie in like
Hawaii Mormon kid thrown into Indiana
right freaking cold weather
um and I think he sought solace in this
person like you know miles miles away
weird take is catfishing that bad like
if you're like I wouldn't mind like
somebody throws up a picture of like a
really pretty girl and you know maybe
it's Carlos on the other end but they're
just like my you know oh Esther like
we're good friends and they give me like
words of encouragement and I'm like oh
this beautiful girl thinks I'm beautiful
makes my day better I can speak to this
so when I got catfished yes it was
helping me through a time where I had a
boyfriend who was playing video games
it's a chronic thing it's a video game
Jesus
um Lana Del Rey Vibes
he was playing video games
um all day every day in the living room
I was paying like rent for and I would
go to my computer download songs on
LimeWire and talk to my catfish and
every day he would call me from
Australia but I knew that he wasn't who
he said he was because when I asked him
his favorite song every single time it
was always some like early 80s like
Banger like he was I remember asking I
was like what what what's your favorite
song and this is a song I Love by the
way I can't knock it but he was like you
know Caribbean Queen I was like I love
that song but then he'd be like yeah
also you know how do I get you alone by
heart I was like okay these are my mom's
[ __ ] favorite songs this cannot it
was your mom the whole time she's like
you should be uh swimming
I really I really wanna I think that
like are you sure you want to eat that
you're like how do you know what I'm
eating
but he would just create this world for
me which I could escape to and I think a
part of me was probably
um probably new but felt really attached
to what he was giving me in that moment
so I don't think that you're wrong but
can we find him her
um yeah so here are the details we need
to know who this person is because like
there's closure for Manti Tales I'm
friends with Nev we can make this happen
Okay so this person on MySpace went by
Amorcito 888 he said he was from
Australia he did have an Australian
accent and his first name was Lorenzo
and that's all I got I could see me
being catfished knowing it's a catfish
but like not letting go that is just not
giving up hope
I I actually think that that's possible
because when he wrote me three years
after and he said I'm in Miami now like
you know I'm in America and I knew he
had he was a catfish at that point like
I still got the flutters oh my God were
you gonna meet him was he trying to meet
you no he wasn't like he would always
pretend kind of like mantai to you like
we'll make plans but the plants always
fall through there's always an excuse
but they do that just to maybe I should
catfish Dave that's happened to me after
I've met people where they keep trying
to hang out with you and then the plans
fall through and was like what the hell
is that so weird I'm like why are you
post catfishing me wait I don't follow
like you hang out with someone and
they're like I want to hang out with you
again let's hang out this week and
you're like okay and then they just keep
not hanging like why do you keep setting
up plans with me and canceling that's an
LA epidemic though it was just so weird
I was like you're setting up these times
to hang out with me you know what that
is such an LA thing like I remember when
I first moved here people who never
wanted to hang out with me would text me
I miss you and I was like what I'm right
here what do you why say that I don't I
don't care it's just so yeah it's so
like you're like yeah you're like just
setting up a situation for me to like
you want me to feel like disappointed or
something what are you doing another
thing that really pertains to Comedy
it's like people being like I really
want to come see your show and I'm like
okay like sure I'll set it up anytime oh
then like sorry I can't make it uh then
the keeps I'm like I this is my job like
you're just making it harder at work
more for me and I don't care dude it's
like now you're apologizing it's like
what just what do you want to say you
know who I be friend okay so at my
dentist at my dentist the guy who
um works in the valet I'm always like
joking with him and he's like he was
like what do you do he's like what are
you doing I was like oh I'm a comedian
he was like oh where do you perform I'm
like telling him where he perform and
stuff side note I want this to be our
origin story that I was originally
yeah imagine Esther actually parking
cars correctly imagine like her driving
opening your car door and putting three
phone books imagine parking all the cars
on a stairwell
sounds efficient ready to go ready to go
sort of very Italian job of you
yeah she's just a great driver it's not
that she's the worst driver she's the
best driver she's escaping that's
exactly what I think about Asian drivers
by the way I think we're too good for
the road
I that's it everyone's like oh Asian
driver I'm like no no no no no no we're
just ballsy we take risks and we don't
follow rules because we don't have them
back home
Asian driver I like I'm trying to break
the stereotypes like I refuse I force an
Asian man to drive me around you will
only be driven by I will I refuse I must
only be driven by people of color and we
must be Asian what so what happened with
your dentist valet I'm like okay I'm
like listen all right he's like I want
to come I'm like okay Eduardo and I like
get his I get his full name and I'm like
all right yeah just go to The Comedy
Store on Wednesday you know I get him in
main room like two seats or whatever
then you know two weeks go by I go back
to the dentist I come out and he's like
not making eye contact I'm like
I'm like did you go to the show and he
goes
I'm so sorry I go I don't
care I don't think you understand how
much I was over extending myself to
begin with how weird it was that I gave
this opportunity to you and he was like
I'm so sorry I didn't know how to be
like I those shows are sold out I I it's
not like we needed to fill the seats
you just took two seats away from other
people
but it was just so funny he was like so
guilty I was like I don't know how to
explain it yeah now you like her you
have the emotions this causes congestion
[Music]
that's what I read you koyla do
yesterday look it turns out I'm no
longer the most educated one about sinus
infections in the room I wonder what
that is is like the sugar builds up or
something I don't know are you also
snorting it like you're snorting rice
wait do you guys know what I am doing
I'm taking a vitamin regimen that uh Rob
Schneider gave me because he used to
have a vitamin company
I'm on schneidermans
Rob shutter gave me a whole list I know
what they are I just take imagine you
wake up looking like him that's how the
air that's the theme of the animal who
knows my Nemesis right why we like had
it he's my friend I form I perform with
them all the time you know that he's
Filipino I love him what yeah is it
because you guys are look eye to eye in
those faces why are you Nemesis just
didn't really get along well on dude's
speech show two Divas I don't know like
he just didn't really like my commentary
I don't think I'm for him I think he's
like you do look like him it could be
editing yeah I think I steal his roles
it's just so weird because he loves me
so much he seeks me out he calls me I
have him and my phone is Robbie I get
calls from Robbie all the time we're
like not on good terms I'm not even
kidding look at him he does have anger
and it does seem towards you
know
oh is that Mateo
like me and Norm had our fight but we
made up we were cool but Rob and I like
it's not really I gotta figure it out
I'll get to the bottom honestly I don't
I kind of like you know how pissed I was
that you were the greatest outfit and
then they were like after you did that
they're like you can't wear Nike and I'm
like you have to let me wear Nike that
smokes so good in it I know that was my
Tony Soprano moment
I loved it yeah look how mad you are
that Rob Schneider is being mean to you
wait also both of the so much is
happening in in this there's even more
than than you know Mateo Lane do you
guys know this one day okay I do the
story about me why did you try to hook
up with them
and is that okay
I have talked about this that my parents
were married by a blind judge and like
because my dad always likes to make a
joke like he should have gotten a
discount whatever and
um I got this DM once from this PO this
comedy family was like I just heard
Mateo Lane on a podcast say that his
grandfather was a blind judge in Chicago
oh my God and I'm like oh my God and so
I I asked my parents to get the name on
their marriage certificate and they were
married by Mateo's grandfather doesn't
that like kind of make us cousins I
think so thank you yeah oh my God you're
gonna try to kiss them
Carlos leave them alone my sweaty Palms
will not permit oh you get to have a
masculine moment it's so sad when they
can't open it sometimes I'll give Todd a
jar and he can't open I'm like Todd this
is so embarrassing when I was on the
road with Marin I had this air one jar
of nuts that I couldn't get open it was
driving me crazy and I was like do I ask
him because what if he can't open it but
he did he was able to open it of course
he was he was like if I was a dude and I
was tasked to open something that I
couldn't open in that moment
I would grab a rock anything I am not I
am not not opening that thing I'm not
going to give it back to you be like I
can't do it Over My Dead Body wait I
need to know what Rob Schneider I need
to know more do you want to do it off
air no there's no there's no there's
honestly nothing more and I don't need
it repaired I'm happy with where we're
at you know he's he would be like the
product if you and I had a child really
Jewish and Filipino are you serious
he's kind of
he's our love child Esther you have to
like him
I can't believe he's he's so Jewish
presenting to me he is yeah he is he
might only like be like a quarter maybe
I saw this article for this like Health
Food guy I follow Max Luca Veer who's
awesome
it says people who are willing to try
new foods are perceived as more
desirable and less sexually restricted
but perceived it doesn't mean that they
are by how many people are knowing what
your new foods are is he just talking
about himself because he like he posts
new things he's eating or maybe he's
talking about like Anthony Bourdain he's
always trying some Beating Heart I
here's the thing I get it in theory it's
like oh if you're willing to try any
food like obviously try a different hole
you're gonna go down on me like that but
I don't like trying new foods and I feel
like I'm a sexually open person I think
there is no correlation you do I don't
think there's a correlation I think
Annie's right I think he's someone who
tries new foods to be viewed as like
sexually unrestricted I feel like it's
the opposite because for me like one of
the main reasons I don't like guys
eating my [ __ ] out is because I have
so many like food allergies and I do try
new foods I didn't know that about you
oh you know that you don't like your
because there's it's a war zone I like
that it's a war zone down there I like
that you have main reasons why like what
are the non-made I don't have to wash
the juju out
um wait but apparently there are real
studies yeah in an initial study 193
undergraduate students were randomly
assigned to read a brief description of
an opposite sex person who is either
willing or reluctant to try new foods
the researchers found that the person
tended to be rated as more desirable
sexual romantic as a more desirable
sexual romantic partner when he or she
was described as being willing to try
new food so it is all about perception
it is perception I will say this um I
don't think I can ever date a guy who
isn't a big just lover of food it's so
boring to date someone I can't do it I
mean it's so boring to date someone that
doesn't want to eat I'll tell you why
this theory is wrong because the guy who
ate my ass religiously every day with
this whole goddamn chest and I mean like
his whole goddamn like he would just
like like he foam at the mouth at the
side of my [ __ ] I hope it wasn't
after your [ __ ]
there's a bad battery acid got in there
he was a rabid for my [ __ ] right just
wanted a [ __ ] like I remember when we
called him he was like hello like he was
like is this my [ __ ]
wait yesterday hello hello yesterday he
sent me pictures that he had taken of my
feet a decade ago and you didn't know
and he said no no no he had cropped out
my body and kept my foot pictures like a
million fetish I didn't know then but
later on he was like nothing like your
feet literally no to this day I've never
met I'm like oh [ __ ] okay
um but thank you for I'm looking at my
pictures I'm like at dinner with Jean
Hong you thought he liked her [ __ ]
but it was really just because he could
see her
my crusty ankle they were like up here I
was like
a side note now that I know your feet
are so desirable we do need a trash
Tuesday only fans okay yeah feed and
greed like Annie said
okay I've been hiding these feet for
years
um no but
um for someone as big of an ass eater as
he was he didn't like sushi
um I would remember I didn't like your
[ __ ] and he only wanted to ask him I'm
not into tuna he was just the most like
Square about food in general and it
really like bummed me out and I remember
no pun intended bum hold her out that
makes sense because I think he's getting
all of his nutrients
definitely not what I was gonna say it's
amazing that you both thought that like
he gets his Thrills in life out of your
[ __ ] so like new foods don't mean
anything to him or they're Bland in
comparison this is a this is a case
where Esther is actually
um she's not with the victim on this one
is he the victim
no she's with him oh you're the victim
he's ravaging your [ __ ]
um something really sweet happened to me
today that this is reminding me of
there's this woman at the um the grocery
store near my house it doesn't end with
her eating your ass I don't it doesn't
but it is about an ass eater some Randy
the ass eater
she is scared of dogs and she's always
like and Randy just wants to play with
her so bad so for like months and months
and months I've lived there for a year
she's just always like and she's like
look it's no offense to your dog I'm
just scared of dogs and I'm always like
Randy leave her alone leave her alone he
wants her so bad right today she goes he
can come over
and she let him come jump up and she's
like okay that's enough I I it like made
my day she conquered her friends yeah
isn't that so sweet I wonder what like
how she that's so cool but also she
literally went it's okay you can come
but also that it was Randy I know you
know she chose Randy he is so choosable
I love raining he's so popular it's
crazy I've never seen anything like it's
he's more popular than your [ __ ] and
your feet
happy how do people make money off of
feed finder
asking for the three of us
because I know that that thing sometimes
I see tick tocks if you're like how do
you how many how much money do you have
in your bank account and she'll be like
you know 900 000 all from feed finder
it's like is that a real thing are
people just like you know five feet are
out there
you have great feet you know my feet are
out there too I don't and I'm not like
ashamed of my feet but there's started a
bit that I never wanted I like your bit
I like the origin of your bit it's like
you don't need to be sexualized what is
this
um this is actually reminding me the
trying new foods of a story I don't
think I've told on here yet which is
like a very pivotal story in me and
Dave's relationship so we're first
dating we were in Vegas and I think I
was like
I kind of wanted to see Dave like take
charge and like get into his masculine
energy and so I said to him I was like
let's go to dinner tonight and I want
you to just order for us I want you to
just like take charge have I told this
yeah on the show yeah but I can't
remember then I'm gonna tell it anyway
yeah to retell that because this is a
good one so he's like
um I'm like take charge like I don't
want to do anything like I don't want to
think you know and so he does he's like
okay fine so he orders a bunch of stuff
and one of the things he orders is
octopus and it gets the table and he's
like try it and I'm like
he's like no you're gonna try it you're
gonna try it and he's like like this new
Dave Persona that I've never met so hot
like that's what I I wanted right but
literally I I start crying
I was so sorry I also have seen that
Dave with you every time I [ __ ] out with
you like Esther stop was he rolling his
eyes
like I just it's so it's such a massive
fail on my part that I like asked him to
do it and then he committed and I
[ __ ] flailed and ruined it but you
banged anyway banged anyway while you
were crying the way Everyone likes it
anyway
that kind of reminds me of how Bobby was
when we first met he has a joke that um
he basically says yeah you know I'm
tired of dating white girls because you
know you go to a restaurant with them
and they're always like what's that you
know with an Asian girl they eat and ask
questions later so I was like oh this
dude must really throw down
so you know I took him out I was like
hey you know like how adventurous are
you with food and he was like I'm Asian
I'm like all right let's go so I took
him to this place and they were
snails everything everything and I'm
telling you like he was the same way
like you could see like tears like his I
want to go it's Bobby my soul mate like
I think so but endless this ruse the
charade and he was like oh you're Asian
Asian I'm like oh my God here I thought
I've had found somebody who was down and
he was just he said he's a poser I
um would love to take a challenge
because I have [ __ ] myself up before
like I've gone to places where I've
spent like 200 and been like just give
it to me like I'm not asking any
questions and I am about to throw up
like I am like this is too this is like
alive still no
and it's too much but I would rather
have that experience than not try I I
really respect that the one thing that I
have
um that really enrages me especially
when I was like younger or like having
to bring my own lunch to school that was
you know like [ __ ] it smelled great
to me but let's say I brought adobo with
rice right and I would open it during
lunch break and then someone would be
like ew what is that when someone like
yucks my Yum I want to [ __ ] gouge
their eyes out oh so they're just
jealous they want to try I'm like [ __ ]
is this better than your [ __ ] dry out
chicken patty I don't know [ __ ] why
don't you close your legs I had the same
experience in elementary school and like
it's so traumatic I'll never eat baloney
again like people made fun of me and it
is there's something when people shame
what you're eating yes people still
eating bologna definitely not actually I
think not in Los Angeles I think there's
a band on it maybe those kids were right
I only ate I would eat them I would Fold
It Up and make the hole
the bologna hole what is baloney now I'm
like why was my mom feeding me that I
have a question I was eating Mortadella
the other day you know it's like it kind
of looks like bologna but it has like
little marbling it has the olives on the
inside it's so good but I brought it as
a snack on a boat one time and someone
was like Hey can you pass the bologna
and I was like I'm eating bologna I
thought I had purchased something like
expensive like a fancy deli meat which I
liked and someone's like pass a [ __ ]
baloney [ __ ] no oh man that was a good
lesson you get over yourself but I just
passed the [ __ ] baloney you know what
I ca I won't knock any food
um I like canned ravioli I like bologna
I love spam I love it [ __ ] anything
any when I'm hungry I will eat anything
I just feel like I am at a point where I
have to stop eating the things that hurt
my body this could just be four weeks
sick any talking but I am like I cannot
[ __ ] with myself anymore we Todd and I
are not eating out anymore we're not
going to restaurants really we're maybe
gonna only go like well he's coming on
the road with me now I'm so excited and
it is Netflix show so for now I've got
him yes and we're bringing Randy oh my
God I'm gonna cry Randy's good on planes
now I don't know what happened he's just
he's over his um what do you call it
like they have like a teenager period I
think he needed to be in first class
but um
yeah so so we're not we're like cooking
at home and when I say we he's cooking
for me and it's so nice I love it it's
like I know what I'm eating I'm not like
my stomach doesn't hurt I'm not [ __ ]
up so it's nice you know the thing about
Dave that is so shocking to me he is a
44 year old man who graduated from
Harvard and this [ __ ] still eats
Lunchables and Uncrustables but those
are not bad choices If You're Gonna Go
processed let's go with the freaking
Uncrustables let's go the saltiest of
the treats that is so filthy that's so
funny that's so juvenile I know but it's
nostalgic and it's comforting that is
true actually like the turkey lunchable
something yeah he's just doing it to
save money with Esther's trying to get
him to buy another house
how do we feel about men in skirts
and we're talking about you Andrew
Schultz we saw you at Burning Man I love
a man in a skirt only because it's like
I watched the tutors
and every like people are like what
happened to men these days everyone is
like wearing I'm like you guys don't
[ __ ] never picked up a history book
or looked at pictures everyone was in
[ __ ] dresses and amulets back then
dude guys have been wearing
eyeliner for right so long they're
wearing nail polish I think it's cute
it's fine super cute and I yeah I think
that I mean if Todd wore a skirt I don't
know if I'd be like let me hop on it but
I think like anything that I'm not used
to at first I'm always like whoa okay
because I have a high school friend that
Carlson I hung out with in New York last
fall and he wore a skirt the whole time
and I was like
I'm surprised but it was all right
totally yeah it's just like you knew
that moment to be like I'm gonna have to
get used to this but I feel like it's
funny like Brad Pitt doing it it's like
all right well we'll see that I mean I
don't love I I'm not a big fan of The
Kilt either it's just you know what it
is it's like I feel like I've
accidentally seen so many dicks and
balls already in my life that it's like
we're just upping the amount it's like I
saw a guy's dick yesterday a guy was
just pissing I'm like it's like the
amount of just unsolicited pain is yeah
and I'm just gonna see your balls I
don't need less between me and penises
out in the world I think like I was
happy with pants I'm happy for people to
be doing what this is a cute look though
that look is so good
so cool you guys whether you're wearing
skirts or
um whether you're Rob Schneider rather
Rob Schneider we we support you of
course you gotta get on the schmeiderman
uh regiment guys
um and as always we will see you guys
next Tuesday with a brand new episode
thank you so much for being here we
would be nothing without you
bye guys or something really bad
[Music]
[Music]